Ein neuer bericht des weltklimarates schlägt jetzt alarm demnach muss jetzt sofort dringend und umfassend geändert werden ansonsten wäre eine
weitreichende zerstörung unseres planeten kaum noch aufzuhalten die welt ist im moment weder in der lage ein klimaziel von
15 noch von zwei grad zu erreichen
der temperaturanstieg dürfte deutlich stärker sein klick zum science fiction hier gibt's täglich science videos abonniert den kanal dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen
Das ist mal eine ansage der weltklimarat hat sich mit dem klima ziel von 1,5 grad befasst dies geschah auf bitten der
entwicklungsländer die besonders stark von den konsequenzen des zwei-grad-ziels
betroffen wären deren ländern nämlich werden im wahrsten sinne des wortes von der landkarte verschwinden bzw
würden durch den anstieg des meeresspiegels
stark schrumpfen das ergebnis in den nächsten zehn jahren
muss endlich
nachhaltig gehandelt werden zitat diese dinge müssen sofort einsetzen die nächsten zehn jahre sind entscheidend in ihren auswirkungen
das sagt hans otto pörtner im gespräch mit dem spiegel der
meereswissenschaftler ist ko vorsitzender der arbeitsgruppe 2 des weltklimarates und damit für den aktuellen bericht entscheidend mitverantwortlich
mit diesen dingen meint er
energieerzeugung landnutzung städtebau verkehr und bau sowie industrie für diesen neuen bericht haben 91 autoren und autorinnen
6000 studien ausgewertet doch diese anderthalb grad marke ist kaum noch zu erreichen da wir bereits einen anstieg von mindestens
1 bis
1,2 grad haben die ergebnisse der studie das klimaziel eines geringeren
temperaturanstiegs würde mit mittlerer sicherheit zehn millionen menschen weniger vom anstieg des meeresspiegels
betreffen der würde nämlich 10 cm weniger ansteigen würden mit hoher sicherheit
signifikant weniger arten aussterben mit mittlerer sicherheit würden etwa 1,5 bis 2,5 millionen quadratkilometer
permafrostböden nicht auftauen hier würde dort gespeicherte kohlenstoff nicht in die atmosphäre entweichen und den klimawandel weiter
beschleunigen die arktis würde mit sicherheit nur einmal im jahrhundert komplett eisfrei stadt jedes jahrzehnt in diesem zustand
beschert uns das offene meer extreme niederschläge und eben extrem wetter würde es mit mittlerer sicherheit deswegen und wegen anderer reduzierter
ursachen deutlich weniger gibt zitat das
vorsorgeprinzip ruf drastisch dazu auf in aktion zu treten so pörtner im spiegel in deutschland die gesteckten klimaziele
aufzugeben oder weiter lustig braunkohle abzubauen ohne rücksicht auf verluste
das geht gar nicht so kann man partner problemlos interpretieren und es ist ja seit der
fraunhofer studie bekannt dass die klimaziele in deutschland erreichbar wären wenn denn nur die politik wollte es muss dringend effektiver
gegen co2 vorgegangen werden so partner in deutschland sind alleine drei millionen menschen vom steigenden meeresspiegel
betroffen so steht es in einem bisher unveröffentlichten
bundestags papier das dem spiegel vorliegt und der extrem heiße sommer wie in diesem jahr der hat vermutlich
zehntausende tote gefordert
extremwetter wie sie immer öfter in den usa aber auch eben hier in europa auftreten
werden immer mehr nur wenn wir das steuer wirklich
herumreißen haben wir noch eine chance und dazu sagt der neue bericht ganz klipp und klar was nötig ist bis
2050 müssen
70 bis 85 prozent des weltweiten stromverbrauchs durch erneuerbare energien erzeugt werden kohle darf ab
2050 nicht mehr genutzt werden feuer muss der verbrauch drastisch
reduziert werden die industrie muss den co2 ausstoß um
75 bis 90 prozent senken co2 muss im großen stil aus der atmosphäre entfernt werden im großen und ganzen
ist die ansage klar in den nächsten 30 jahren müssen die co2 emissionen bis 2050 eben auf null gesenkt werden
co2 das dann noch in die luft gelangt zum beispiel durch den flugverkehr
muss wieder aktiv aus der luft entfernt werden laut pörtner gibt es so seine privatmeinung keinen grund wie arbeitsplätze und weitere
vorwände das erreichen der ins auge gefassten die maschine zu verzögern denn im zweifel sei ergänzte ich mal gibt es mehr tote
durch den klimawandel und zwar auch hier in europa als
arbeitsplätze bewahrt werden aber im moment sieht es nicht danach aus wenn ich mal die realität sondern nur die
zusagen der industrie nationen im rahmen des pariser
klimaabkommens nehmen so der bericht des weltklimarates steigt die temperatur um insgesamt 2,6 bis 4 grad
weltweit wird das aber und abermillionen menschen betreffen und dann wird es auch hier in europa extrem ungemütlich
ich werde auf jeden fall dran wenn ihr als erstes neues zum klimawandel und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert und zur begrüßung
gibt es noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
glocke vergessen und darunter geht es weiter auch dafür drauf klicken so kann deutschland
seine klimaziele doch noch erreichen da geht es um die von greenpeace in auftrag gegebene studie des
fraunhofer institutes ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt bleibt